and i believe we are now live
on
welcome
welcome everybody to our digital
marketing master class how to map the
customer journey and create effective
marketing content for it
uh it's a live demonstration with our
one of our top instructors bernadette
chambers who is also the founder of the
socialite hive
and more about her in a moment my name
is stuart creek i'm a marketing manager
here at simply learn
i am
going to be behind the scenes
logging your questions for bernadette
for the q a
please put those into the q a box in
webex as you see in the controls here
uh you can put in chat messages which we
will see but
for the questions for bernadette
best place to put them is in q a
and we'll cue those up and get to them
in the q a part of the
event
uh we also have a few polls that we
would like to do
um
and we're going to start with one now
which is very simple
you'd like to know how much work
experience you have
get an idea a feel for the audience so
bernadette can address it properly
and
also we asked how you're doing today
it's something we've been asking
throughout the pandemic just to see how
people are holding up
as things keep shifting
and hopefully we're getting to the end
of this latest
surge and uh hopefully we'll be in a
quiet period so
checking in without
everyone
and we'll end the poll in five seconds
and
here is the result
so we have a pretty
even distribution of folks uh about a
third of you are
seasoned professionals in the 10 plus
year category
about a quarter of you are
still in
university or college and
uh there's a
even distribution of people between so
with that and with the fact that uh
almost everybody's doing well or doing
okay
we hope that this session will
uh improve
the outlook for people who are in that
third category and with that i'm going
to introduce
bernadette
bernadette chambers is as i mentioned
the founder of the socialite hive she's
an entrepreneur
a social media marketing consultant
um an internationally recognized digital
marketing trainer works with many of our
top programs here at simply learn
an expert
in seo especially for social media
and
she has a
11 plus year
background and we're very fortunate to
have her here today
so welcome bernadette and i am going to
uh turn it over to you
yeah i hear you now
excellent
hi there nice and i see you
okay and i'm gonna shift sharing
to privilege to you so that you can
share your screen
okay excellent
as soon as i see it then i will
hit the button and we'll get started
and you have it now
excellent thank you
well hello everyone and welcome i hope
that you all are having a great day
and as steward said um we're going to be
talking specifically about
the key elements of mapping out your
customer journey and as many of you know
the customer journey in time in terms of
how people become customers in business
in most of anything has dramatically
changed and so this graphic that you're
seeing um right now is from central
digital
and the reason why i pulled it is
because it used to be defined as three
different points awareness consideration
and then the decision-making process
where a purchase happens
now there are several different points
sometimes a customer can go through
almost 120
plus points
before they actually make a decision so
this element of your business of your
organization or wherever you land on the
totem pole
is super important so that you know
exactly how to plan these things so
hopefully you gather a lot out of that
and just to reiterate what we're going
to be talking about
um today we're going to be discussing or
understanding the various touch points
in the customer journey
using competitive research
to support the findings
how to effectively pinpoint the
appropriate content types for the
journey
and then we're going to make the most of
nurturing the relationship to increase
customer engagement so those that don't
make
um the decision to make a decision right
away we're going to use what we have in
order to continue to nurture them down
the pipeline so that we can get them to
make a decision later on
so
really quickly what i want you guys to
do is i want you guys to shift
shift from thinking about your companies
and the various products that you offer
and i want you to shift to the customers
what are some things just in general you
can type them in the chat or you can
just kind of think about them but what
are some things that customers typically
think about before they arrive at your
solution you can type it in the chat i'm
going to use the example of meal
prepping and meal delivery service for
our demonstration here
it's easy it's quick and it helps people
to stay in mind
price
do they always think about price
so this is what we're going to talk
about today
how to get it as cheap as possible so
typically when people go to google
the first step is the how
how are they going to achieve something
and who's going to provide them
with the possibilities of what to
achieve it with does that make sense let
me know in the chat it is usually not
price price is a non-factor in the
beginning of the customer journey they
look to find answers so in our example
i'm going to use hellofresh
and one of the problems that
bill prepping and these types of
services solve is the difficulty of
planning meals right so the first thing
that i'm going to do is i'm putting
myself
in the mindset of the customer and i
want to figure out
what is the problem that i'm looking to
solve
usually in meal prepping you're not sure
what to eat you're tired of eating the
same things you don't want to spend
money yep that's correct convenience you
don't want to spend money on fast food
you want to actually cook healthy meals
for you and your family so as a marketer
i'm going to begin to think like a
customer and the first search term that
i'm going to put in is i'm going to put
in how to meal plan
easily how to meal plan easily because i
want it quick i want it fast and i want
it easy i don't want to be burning
things and all of that and then i have
to start all over by fast food anyway
right
so as i'm going here one of the things
that i'm also going to do
is i'm going to engage in the people
also ask section are you all familiar
with the people also ask section let me
know in the chat
all right excellent the people also ask
section is a really great tool that
everyone has access to to use to
understand
what types of questions that our
audience is going to have in the
awareness stage in the awareness stage
because when we go to these we're going
to determine which type of questions are
in the awareness which type of questions
are in the consideration which types of
questions are going to be in the making
process so that we can
appropriately assign whatever content
that we need to create internally to
guide our customers down this belt
so in the people also ask section you
have how do i make my meal plan easier
what are the five basic steps of meal
planning how do i create a food plan how
do i make my weekly plan so all of these
questions here and you'll find if you
click on this
more questions are going to populate
more questions are going to populate but
you want to stick to questions that you
know the ordinary
person is going to choose right the
ordinary person is going to choose so at
this point i'm going to introduce this
little graphic to you because as you're
doing this research you're going to be
basically tallying where you're going to
put these questions
so in the awareness phase
there could be goals
or there could be some light goals that
you're trying to make
um from light to heavy from
least important to most importance so at
this point you want to collect
all of the questions that relate to this
area so you can figure out exactly what
type of content is going to suffice
right so i'm going to open up my little
notepad here and i'm just going
you've frozen momentarily it should come
back
bernadette's connection is frozen for
just a moment so let's wait for her to
come back
internally oh okay
you're back you were frozen just at the
moment you said let's open the notepad
okay all right so sorry about that i
don't know what happened probably
was doing too many things
all right so what i was saying was it in
the featured snippets
it takes roughly
ten thousand to a hundred thousand
searches within a certain amount of time
in order for google to deem these bits
inside of the people also ask section so
those of you who are responsible for seo
in your organizations you want to try to
get someone who is skilled at or has the
skill set to get you in the featured
snippets
so one of the things to note when i open
up my notepad here is of course probably
roughly around four to five different
questions that we see here first
question and i
make a note of that real quick
oh it's thinking
and by the way uh
you might want to turn off your camera
burden that because i think we're
getting
um occasional hiccups okay you can
reduce the bandwidth there all right i'm
just gonna
all right i'm gonna turn the video off
so that way it doesn't
so how do i make my meal plan easier
how do i create my food plan so this is
another good one usually the awareness
section is going to focus on the how not
the what
not the price not any of these things
and your job at this point whether it be
in video well
they're entering these questions these
questions
okay um the what maybe let me see if i
can find one other question before i
move
i'm gonna move into the
next one how do i make my weekly meal
plan okay this one's pretty good
all right
so this
i would characterize as my awareness
stage
awareness stage
now in consideration
in consideration
at this point
you're starting to see
some of the articles that come along
here right come along here
now right here at the top you'll notice
that there's an ad here there's an ad
for hellofresh
and basically it starts to answer those
questions that those
folks would ask so
tired of take out getting sick of
grocery shopping try hellofresh get 15
free meals i'm going to highlight this
bit of information because this is a key
performance indicator or a kpi of a
really great offer that will catch the
attention of those folks who are looking
for alternatives to take out who are
looking for alternatives to whatever it
is that they're looking for in meal
planning because at this point we don't
know whether or not our customers are
looking for
meal ideas to go grocery shopping or for
us to provide it for them right
now in the consideration
in the consideration at this point
they're looking for the best solutions
so at this point i have to get into my
into the mind of the customers to find
out what is the best solutions for
grocery shopping what's the best
solution for meal planning what is the
best alternative for some of the
elements that i might find cumbersome
right so i'm gonna go here best
alternatives
to
grocery shopping
right
so here are some
ideas what's the most efficient way to
grocery shop what's the least popular
grocery shopping day what's on the
grocery list affordable alternatives to
grocery shopping these are all
options that we can use to target some
of these folks that want to know okay
all of these plans in the first of how
to do my meal planning it requires
grocery shopping how can i get rid of
that how can i get rid of that
cumbersome element right
so what you see here is you see a switch
does everyone see that
now you see from the how
to what
in which do you guys see that
when you see search terms like this
when you see search terms like this
you can start to kind of assimilate and
start to kind of see okay these types of
questions means that this consumer or
this customer has now moved from
awareness to now deciding which one is
going to be best so you now have which
online grocery is the best
which grocery delivery app is the best
which online grocery shopping is
cheapest all of these different things
and if you scroll down here
who do we see that's familiar
that we saw in the first part of the
journey
let me know here in the chat who do you
see that's familiar we see hello fresh
they're they're right there in present
the ad of hello fresh they're right
there and present because they are again
sending that message that hey
now we know that you're looking for
grocery shopping and they made sure to
put
in here the actual issue getting sick of
grocery shopping do you see how the
messaging change from the first met
message to the next message
that's how you know that this is moving
down the pipe
okay so i'm just going
to choose the witch
so if i were a customer at this point
i've seen hello fresh twice
so now at this point i want to start
looking at maybe some reviews okay i've
seen hello fresh twice
i'm probably going to start getting at
this point i'm probably going to start
to get social media ads i'm probably
going to start to get you know little
messages
let me see what the reviews are
usually and think about how you guys
look for products and services right
think about how you kind of approach
that area
and when you're approaching a specific
area and you see a company or a service
provider or a particular product what's
the next thing that you do
what's the next thing that you do when
you see that product over and over and
over again
that's correct we're going to the
reviews so since we've seen hellofresh
i'm going to start going to hellofresh
reviews
okay
and lo and behold look what we have here
this is what i call the strong
consideration phase now notice something
one of you
a few of you said that base that you saw
price
in the beginning
when we did the consideration phase
did we see price and now people also ask
section
and if not what did we see
we didn't see price
we saw the how they were attempting to
find out how exactly we were going to
accomplish solving our issue
now we're starting to see them move into
price
so we have here reviews we want to see
what are the reviews what are the what
are the types of content here so in this
particular case
blogs such as review blogs or taste
tests or customer testimonials these are
going to be
pivotal for all of these uh these
questions
right so we see here
i tried a meal prep service for a week
here is what i thought then we see here
is hellofresh actually good and there is
an article from the honest
customer giving that person the answer
that they want how much this hellofresh
really cost
hellofresh themselves has a blog post
that they have
created for that particular customer
is hellofresh actually affordable you've
got hellofresh here still meeting their
questions because they are now
in the consideration slash decision
making phase does everyone follow me so
far let me know in the chat
so ultimately this is the way that
you're going to start mapping out and
creating
what it is that you're going to be
focused on in each step of the journey
and if you are not the actual company
then you're going to look at competitors
like i did here if i was doing a
delivery service if i was doing a
delivery service or i was doing
something to that effect and i would use
these types of things to crap how i'm
going to come up with my content i want
to go back to the graphic that i showed
you before because when you're creating
your customer journey map these are the
various areas that you want to consider
and you want to create i'm also going to
provide you guys with a link um with a
really good article from hubspot that
actually shows you guys how you can map
them out they give you like a blank
um a blank tool that you can fill in but
as you can see here you see the customer
activities they'll hear something from a
friend they'll see it online or offline
they'll read newspapers they'll do all
of these different things
then they go in and compare the
alternatives which is what we saw here
so then you start to see search terms
like best meal delivery service so
you'll do best
meal kit delivery service that's some of
the search terms that you're using
next you want to come to the decision so
you want to bring them to the place you
want to bring them to the place where
they're making the decision and they
have an offer that they can't refuse
when they get to the decision making
process and they get to your website you
want to bring them to an offer that they
can't refuse so after we're done with
this infographic i'm actually going to
show you how hellofresh does a really
beautiful job at this process
then after they've made the decision now
it's time for the actual delivery or the
fulfillment of the service that you want
and then you want that same customer to
re-engage back with these great reviews
that we read from here so you kind of
see the customer goals you see the find
the best solution find the products
order effortlessly you see the various
touch points like word of mouth the
website the app the delivery service
phone email or chat you see all of these
things here
you also see where the experience is so
you want to know exactly from start to
finish what they feel so that way you
can use those key points to ensure that
you're delivering on every part of the
process
and by this time when you're looking
internally and i'll get to questions in
a bit i saw you a few of you had some
questions we'll get to those in a little
bit
but when you're
addressing the experience in the
customer journey and you're mapping that
out it's important for you to look
internally to see where certain
bottlenecks might be in order for you to
address those so that you can
continuously move them down the funnel
if there is a specific part of the
process where you feel like you're not
meeting the goal you're not meeting the
the
customer expectations then you want to
explore that the next part is you've got
to align the customer journey with the
business goals and as you see here on
this graphic
i'll try to make this a little bigger
for you guys so you can really see
you want to align the business goals
with the customer goals but still
keeping the customer at the center of
that business goals so if you're doing
in increased awareness what are some
ways you would think that hellofresh
might
let me try to make it
it's kind of pixelated whenever it gets
bigger can you guys see it a little
better it's a little bit blurry but i'll
read what it says
okay
so the business goal here is increase
awareness and interest
so where would we what kinds of things
would you see
um in this particular process
if i'm trying to increase awareness as
hellofresh the company what are some
things that i would actually see in this
process i probably see a bunch of how-to
videos i'd probably get in my tick-tock
fee people actually preparing the meals
i would actually see you know their
unboxing process so i would see like
what types of things that i get in the
hellofresh kit and so on and so forth so
as you're thinking about that or as
you're thinking about the various stages
you want to look to see
what types of things that you want to
craft do i want to do a video do i want
to do a blog post do i want to
do um
yes i can provide the link after we're
done
i want to see if i want to make any
types of infographics things like that
so let's take a look
at one the offer and two the type of
content and how we measure whether or
not it's going to be successful for us
so i'm actually going to go to the
hellofresh site
another way to do this
they have it to spend but we can also go
to the actual ad and click on the ad
it probably wouldn't cost them all that
much money anyway
maybe a dollar probably cost them a
dollar to click on this
oh
it's still thinking taking a little
while
oh no
let me try and refresh and see sorry
about that guys
here we go
so what's the first thing that we see
as it relates to the customer journey
things that we
talked about earlier from the questions
that we had
what is it that we see right off of the
back
that addresses some of those things
that we saw in the customer journey
process when we were looking towards
google what do we see
convenience take the stress out of meal
time the layout i can see their plans i
can see what it is that they offer
i can see why i should choose them
so no skipping on meals i can see your
chats it's okay you don't have to say
out loud but i can see your chat so no
skimping
on on certain parts of the meals no
commitment whatsoever the most five star
reviews fresh and affordable what i
really love about what they've done here
is is all of the things that you and i
on this webinar have talked about in the
process of what you need to see to make
a decision as a consumer they have it
right here on the front part of the page
then it has what's inside of the box so
they know straight out of the gate
before they press
to add to cart they know what's what
it's going to come in easy to follow
recipes high quality ingredients
convenient meal kits that fit perfectly
in the refrigerator a fun cooking
experience that makes you feel
unstoppable i've literally seen kids on
youtube
cooking hello fresh meals
then of course they have based on what
people want to choose do you want meat
and vegetables oh do you want meat and
veggies do you want something family
friendly do you want vegan do you want
fit and wholesome whatever your
your meal preference is
these are things that they have
organized so that you can look at the
menu
the other part that they have that's
really amazing is the social proof look
at this little kid here he's helping
make dinner he has his little knife and
chopping up things
he has a chef hat on the dogs over here
with the recipe card there's families
here
this stokes the emotion of my family and
i can have family time together we can
really get together and make these meals
and not feel overwhelmed with what's for
dinner it's really a team sport when it
comes to hellofresh and of course
there's other questions that back up the
exact questions that they see online so
how does hello fresh meal kit delivery
service work which food meal plans and
recipes the do they offer how many times
a week all of these different things so
once the customer gets to this website
this is the part that i share with you
all where it's really a nurturing
process after this they're really doing
a really great job here of nurturing
folks but let's say for instance for
whatever reason
all of this stuff they get distracted
they decide they're not gonna go for it
let's take a look at what the channels
that they're actually on what does these
what do these things look like
so let's start off by going to their
instagram we'll take a look at instagram
now if your company or your service is
on the social media platforms regardless
of what it is
you want to look at the highest engaging
content that is created and you want to
recreate it with your company's voice
branding captions and things like that
and here are the things that you want to
make note of when you're doing this
right
so let's say for instance i'm looking
for
some highly engaging content here so i'm
looking for things that have
high comments high
um likes
views things like that
so i notice here right off of the bat
they have
yep i know i choose this on purpose so
that you'll pay attention
so right here in the section we see that
this image here has
519 likes and 12 comments so we'll go
here
and we'll look at that specifically i
guess i have to log in because they
won't let me get away with not being
logged in so
too bad
oh i'm on a different device
let's go to reels because i don't have
time to do all of the login and stuff
like i would in my class
but if we're going to reels which by the
way is a very popular
piece of content that's kind of being
spread throughout all social media
channels
i would go to some that has some really
really high engagement so this would be
a really great example
of really high engagement this would
also be an example of really high
engagement and if you notice their post
versus their reels
have higher engagement and higher views
than some of the posts do so if i were
in the marketing manager seat or you
were in the marketing manager's seat
what piece of content would you focus
the most on would you focus on the reals
or would you focus on the post
absolutely the reels
the reels they're not paying for these
views they're not using budget and money
to get attention for this stuff
right they're literally getting organic
views from people who are just
interested in what those folks have to
say so while i would still do my post i
would focus and bring the company
towards reels okay
let me just dive into a few of
a few of your questions not
too many
is reals is the reels open for all or a
specific company reels and content like
that is open for any specific company it
is not unless you have some sort of a um
a restriction on your account
you can definitely go in and do reels
and it does not matter if you have a
consumer good or you have a service any
opportunity that you get to show someone
the how and capture their attention then
you can do anything else to bring them
down the customer journey remember the
awareness stage in the customer journey
starts with the how
how is this service or this product
going to bring me to the point where i
am actually
um solving my problem or i'm one step
closer to solving my problem or what
have you the other thing that i want you
guys to mention in terms of reels is i
want you to look at the angles that
these things are shot and as you see the
view count and some of the engagement
count go up
you start to see
top view shots these top view shots are
what get people interested to even click
to press play
on some of these reels so anything that
highlights the product and you want to
use the same kind of methodology of
researching in your respective field so
while we're just using this as a demo
example you want to go to your field and
see on the platform that you think that
you're going to get the most engagement
on you want to see what type of content
is performing well
right now as opposed to going in and
trying to reinvent the wheel
the next place that i know and this will
be the last one just for time's sake i i
could go on and on about this all day
but unfortunately i don't have the time
we're gonna go to pinterest
because i know for sure that hellofresh
has kind of an audience there so we'll
go to pinterest and we can do some
research on pinterest to see exactly
what types of images what types of
content is performing well on pinterest
so right here we can go and type in
hellofresh
and we can do hello fresh usa
and then we see here that they have 97.1
followers is everyone able to hear me
okay i got someone that's saying my
voice is breaking up everyone can hear
me might be the connection on your in
everyone's saying that it's clear
so you want to see here look again you
see a pattern you see a pattern with how
they have this content laid out and the
content is laid out with all of these
top shots that you see here starting
with the food starting with all of these
different areas so you know if you're in
the meal delivery service that any type
of content that you put out you want to
leave with something that's appetizing
you want the customer to engage in the
content right off the bat so
unfortunately my presentation has to
come to an end but i'm going to leave
you with this one point this is the
customer journey map from hubspot i am
going to share this link with you so
that you know exactly um how to access
this you download it to your google
drive you may have to fill in some small
information but this is absolutely free
and it does come from hubspot and
basically it prompts you into all of the
different areas that your potential
customers could be thinking about now
the ones that i find highly helpful for
people who are in the service and
product industry
is customer journey map six and customer
journey map nine
the day in the life ask what is the
customer thinking what are their main
priorities what are their biggest pain
points how do they interact with the
product or service
how can our product be better utilized
these are questions that you can use
internally as prompts with your teams in
order for you to go in and find out
what's the best type of content that we
need to provide to ask some things like
this to be able to drive our audience
down the customer journey so that they
can make a final decision and this is a
again this is a really great tool
hubspot does an incredible job of giving
us these prompts you can also use tools
like miro and things like that but
ultimately
the one thing that you want to keep in
mind here is
when the customer journey starts usually
the mindset is the how
then in the consideration phase it's the
what in which one and in the decision
making phase at this point we're going
in to look at what types of offers what
am i willing to spend in all of those
different areas and at that point you
should be thinking about
infographics blogs content like you saw
hello fresh do here you want landing
pages that drive them down that process
i hope that this was informative and
that you learned a lot now i'm going to
go ahead and open the floor up for
questions and get you guys these links
in the chat so that you're able to um
engage
great
thank you bernadette that that was a
marvelous presentation um a great lesson
that you're taking through and a number
of the people in the audience commented
that
they loved your energy and the fact that
you went right into the good stuff so
i've got some of their questions cued up
here
one of them from jerem is what are the
key digital technologies that people can
use
to support customers moving along in the
in the journey
so one of the things that i would
definitely suggest is having some sort
of a mapping process
um a a chat process inside of your
website um also anything that responds
so autoresponders on social media
um really understanding your heat map of
your website and um what people are
actually clicking on you also want to
measure the engagement and analytics on
your social media channels just in case
because you should at this point
be
retargeting folks that are visiting your
website whatever process in the journey
and you also want to make sure that
you're
um using things like um a a a really big
trend that's happening right now in
digital marketing it's like ai tools to
determine like
what people are looking at so you might
want to research those but ultimately
the main thing is
heat maps um to help track where people
are clicking you can also utilize just
basic tools like google analytics
and really understanding where what
pages they're visiting the most and
things like that
great
um
but
aguasri asks um
how do cus how do you know as a marketer
that your customers are moving uh
okay let me read the question directly
because i don't want to verify says hi
bernadette how do i know that the
customers from my website are moving
from an awareness phase to a
decision-making phase
well one of the things is is that you
have to have the content
to support where they're going and the
cus the the types of questions and the
type of pages that they visit are going
to shift now over the last 10 years
there are several different types of
code and tools that you can put into
your website that actually screen
records
what customers are doing and then you
can tell where the hiccups are it does
take a little bit of back work to just
trying to figure out but let's say for
instance i'll just give you just a
surface let's say for instance
i'm a customer with hellofresh i've
gotten to the website and i go to
how many times a week
they deliver
well the heat map is going to pick up on
how many of those customers are clicking
here the heat map is going to tell us
where they're clicking if they go to
view our plans they're really moving
down the funnel but if they're clicking
on more questions they still haven't
quite decided if we're a good fit for
them right
if we see in the heat mapping that
they're going into family friendly or
they're clicking on you know what types
of meals or they go to our blog or
things like that then we know for sure
that they're still in the consideration
phase but if they for whatever reason on
first try
start to go into more purchase type
actions such as registering or putting
in their address or add to cart or
checking out then we know for sure that
that person has moved from considering
to actually making a decision they just
might have gotten lost along the way
okay
uh from our linkedin audience uh esha
has two questions that are
great
one is who are the correct set of people
in your organization
who should get involved in the process
of customer journey mapping
that's a great question i would say
anyone who's on your email marketing
team
anyone who is responsible for web
development so uh creating the landing
pages
anyone who is responsible for the media
buying so paid marketing if you have an
seo person they need to be in on the
mapping of the customer journey as well
um any type of content writers or blog
writers all of these folks are going to
be in this meeting because they're all
going to be identifying what stages the
customers actually go into and what
types of content need to meet them at
the various stages then they will come
in with their measurement tools so that
you as the marketing manager knows
exactly what the messaging is and
whether or not you're meeting your goals
you should be looking at how many people
are getting stuck in the decision-making
phase is the offer pungent enough are we
are we really giving that those folks an
offer that they can't refuse i mean get
free 16 free meals with your purchase
that that in and of itself is
is an offer that one can't refuse so
hopefully that um that kind of clears up
who you should
reach out to
okay
and she also asks uh do customer
journeys represent ideal
scenarios of how the customer thinks
and
how do you make them flexible enough to
to
represent what happens when somebody
goes off that ideal path
well the beauty is is that
anything in this industry is flip and
while the customer
actions can be predictable after a while
you might always you you never know when
you're going to get a wrench thrown in
the path right but ultimately we have
enough data as marketers and we have
enough tools as marketers to always
re-engage the large majority of our
audience so if you're losing people at
the add to cart phase someone on your
team should be able to identify why
maybe the offer is not clear enough
maybe there's a bug in the website maybe
there's something going on but for
certain
when you identify where they're going
off the path it makes it easier for you
to kind of troubleshoot and respond and
address those various areas so that you
kind of keep them in like a
troubleshooting manual if you will for
the various personas and you can have
several different customer journey maps
for the various personas that you have
within your organization you don't have
to have one cookie cutter this is where
you would sit down with your teams to
determine if i have you know nancy's
who's 35 with three children versus john
and sally who are a newlywed couple does
that make sense
and
thank you for that the
mukesh asked a couple of questions one
is is
this advice
is this lesson applicable to all sizes
of companies
or is it more applicable
to a large company versus a small one
um
when you think about
that's a really great question and when
you think about companies i always ask
my students
do you do business with the company or
do you do business with people
and the answer should always be i do
business with people so it doesn't
matter the size of the company it
doesn't matter the service of the
product the product is solving a problem
for someone who is in direct line with
the purpose of that product so when
you're doing methodologies like this you
always want to think about how does our
company how does our product or service
solve the problem for the consumer who
is paying our bills essentially and how
do they
how do they become
one of those persons who is actually now
exchanging money with us versus just
researching about us that's essentially
where you start because i see a lot of
questions about where do i start how do
you as a consumer become just someone
who's researching online to whipping out
your credit card and paying the price it
doesn't matter how big it is it doesn't
matter if it's b2b it doesn't matter if
you're servicing ceos or or accountants
or whoever whatever service or product
that you provide it is solving a problem
for x in that organization and you have
to segment and take the time to segment
what those things are which would mean
that you have to kind of map out and
journey out the day in the life of that
person which uh hubspot does a really
great job of you kind of looking at what
those pain points are
that kind of um
relates to the question phoebe asks
which is uh does the customer
journey help determine the buyer persona
for the brand or
is it possible the other way around
um actually you will you would build the
buyer persona first
because then the customer journey
actually takes that person think of it
as kind of a a cartoon
you have to build the character first
then you have to then you go into all
right now that i've built this character
i know that she's between the ages of 25
to 35 she's a mom she has this
responsibility that responsibility
now you're going into the day of the
life so now you're walking with this
particular character
um i do know some marketers that do the
day in the life first before they build
a persona but i kind of find that
if you don't necessarily have a
prototype
then you can't really research and find
out what they're feeling
and
a really another really great tool of
kind of finding out how they arrive to
the point that they become customers is
definitely positive reviews because
people take the time out to tell you you
know i was thinking about new ideas for
things and stumbled across an ad for
hellofresh or stumbled across an ad for
um
ghost green chef or whatever meal plan
service i didn't know if i was going to
order you start to craft those different
emotions inside of your your journey so
that you know what to meet them at
okay
uh interesting question from paharsh
which is uh if i already have a website
and i want to implement a funnel model
in the website for seo
what changes should i look at making
what what can i do and how would it
affect my website ranking if i make
these changes
that's a really great question the way
that the big boys do it is they have a
landing page
which later on takes them to the website
it is easier more cost effective and
does not change your ranking if you
already have a website ranking
to do a landing page it also condenses
the information that you have because
while websites are excellent tools to
bring the customers down the journey a
lot of times it has so much information
that it's overwhelming you have to think
when people are researching stuff what's
the main place that they research from
probably 90 to 80 to 90 is going to be
from their mobile phones which you are
competing with notifications text
messages all of these different things
so having a landing page will help you
to kind of condense the information down
bring them down to the process once
they've gotten once they have provided
you with their information then you can
redirect it to your web page and that
way they can have more time to kind of
look at more information that you have
to offer
okay
um i do want to ask a question from
practic which is generally what is the
scope of digital marketing as a career
oh my
so
digital marketing has several different
disciplines in in domains it splices out
to about nine of them
and as a marketer myself um while i am
very familiar with all domains in the
digital marketing space
my top favorite and most easiest in my
opinion is consulting and media buying
media buying actually brings a lot of
straightforward actions i can calculate
revenue better but you're looking at
email marketing seo we now have ai and
ai interpretation you have um text
message marketing you have web
development you have um
[Music]
social media and social media engagement
you have now content creation content
marketing is is taking a huge boom you
have influencer vetting and influencer
marketing
a really great place to understand what
the career looks like if you go to
linkedin
and you type in digital marketing where
the jobs are
you'll see the various things that
they're asking for that companies are
asking for and that'll help you to
determine where if you're a beginner and
you have no idea where to get started
look for the types of things that
they're looking for look for the types
of jobs that they're looking for the
types of skill sets
collaboration link building content
marketing pay-per-click
retargeting all of these areas or areas
that you can say all right the majority
of the jobs in my area now i am um i'm
in the us but some of you are in other
countries change your country
and look at what types of things that
you see kind of a trend for maybe source
like maybe 10 to 12 job postings and
whatever you're seeing a trend with
that's the ones that i would go with
that's the skill sets that i would go to
train myself or educate myself on in
order for me to be competitive in this
space but it can be as broad as you want
it to be and it can also be as defined
as you want it to be
okay
very good um
just a couple more questions before we
have to wrap up
um
me anna asks how often
should you update your content how often
should it be posted to sure
um i would say uh monthly i would say
that you should make out a 30-day
calendar
um measure what's working and what's not
um
and and create as much as possible
content is is very very important in
this space
because that's how the customers engage
if you're wanting to complete compete on
platforms like tick tock um instagram
reels things like that you got to be
cranking out content weekly because
when you slow down on your postings um
and i'm not saying that you have to uh
do it all in one week you can do it for
a 30 day calendar but at least be
posting at least once a day but you want
to be on top of it because when you're
not engaging with your audience then the
platforms kind of look as you as oh
they're not really serious about
engaging with the audience so we've got
to kind of go down a bit we've got to
um
limit their appearance in our for you
pages and things like that so it's
highly competitive in terms of content i
would suggest at least making the plan
out for it for 30 days and posting daily
so that you can keep up the engagement
for your companies
and that relates to the question peace
asks about how to attract more audience
when using reels
so that
basically your advice is to make sure
that you're
posting them on a regular basis and what
other advice would you obvious
offer for
people using wrinkles
sure um so one of the things is is a lot
of people are concerned about negative
feedback or comments or negative reviews
because they're more present
honestly you're going to get that
regardless the best thing that you can
do is you can use reels you can use
content like this to address some of
those concerns
you always want to use positive content
to offset the negative don't be off put
by negative reviews because you have to
think about it everyone's not going to
like your product they might try it and
it doesn't fit for them but you always
want to say hey i'm concerned but in
terms of
when you it you want to be as consistent
as possible you want to make sure that
you're entertaining as as possible you
don't have to do dances and you don't
have to you know do the latest trend on
tick tock or the latest trend on
instagram but you want to capture that
person who's scrolling down the timeline
just kind of mindlessly scrolling to
give them something interesting so
that's why studying the angles of the
content studying the lighting the type
of content is very very important and
this is something that you want to keep
on top of on a regular basis if you see
something that works
and hits it out of the park
you want to try and test that thing
again if it hits out of the park the
second time then you have your formula
and you want to recreate content
different content with the same format
so that you're keeping your audience
engaged you see a lot of that on tick
tock where you have people that make
very similar videos but with different
content
that's what you want to do you want to
find out what your formula is quickly
engage and be consistent
great
yeah i'm thinking of one of my favorite
social media personalities is the guy
aussie man
and
his
videos are
definitely
mostly locked into a format of
taking clips from other internet sources
and doing an audio commentary over them
and it works for him so
um you find out what works for you
and
make that a kind of a consistent
practice and a formula as bernadette
said
absolutely
uh
mark i'm going to
ask this last question before we have to
move on mark asks
starting out in digital marketing would
you suggest that he specializes in a
particular field like seo or should he
learn several different disciplines
across digital marketing
um again i would defer back to what is
what is your dream job what do you want
to work in because if you're not
interested in seo you're going to burn
out quickly
what interests you the most and if
you're just kind of tipping your toe in
you might want to just take maybe you
know a light class to start and then say
okay i'm interested in this i'm
interested in this and then maybe go
into a specialization
it's just like being a doctor
you have generalists or general practice
doctors you have heart surgeons you have
um optometrists you have
a gynecologist you have all of these
different specializations
you have to figure out which one that
you're most passionate about and
unfortunately there's no uh kind of
cookie-cutter way to that um i'd see a
question on the corner of my eye yes
there's uh heat mapping for mobile apps
if you google them there's a ton of them
but for sure you want to uh you
definitely want to explore all areas if
you're not locked into something first
figure out which one you're most
passionate about and go from there for
myself i love media buying and i love
content creation so those are things
that i can do all day not feel like i'm
working feel like i'm playing i love
going out taking my phone out my gimbal
out my camera out taking pictures of
stuff putting it together editing it and
posting on tick tock these are the
things that i enjoy doing so
you don't want to feel like it's work or
that you're pressured or things like
that
okay
and
we have a question from rudy that i
wanted to address which is you know when
writing content how do you write faster
with a lot of engaging content and
that's a big part of my job here at
simply learn so
um i can offer that
um
you you just have to be good at writing
um and you have to look for a lot of
different ideas out in the world
um
in terms of what's in the news what's
on social media what are people talking
about or interested in hearing about
and
you also need to be able to turn to
other people who can help you with the
actual writing
if you get overwhelmed uh people like
freelancers um what would you add to
that bernadette i was just gonna say
definitely if that's not your role in
digital marketing then i would
definitely outsource content writing i
would use a properly vetted platform um
you don't want
things like bots or things like that
creating i'm a little iffy about plr
which is private label writing um
because lots of people purchase it some
of them use it without even editing it
but i would go on to content creation
curation platforms put what you want out
there and then have someone that you are
going to be working with long term
because remember content strategy and
content marketing is a long term thing
great
with that i'm going to move on first off
thank you very much bernadette this has
been a fantastic
lesson for for everyone and um
let me go ahead and take back the
screen sharing and i will
reshare my screen
we want to ask a second poll here
so
allow me to
and
this whole question has to do with
what people have been asking about in
terms of the different
disciplines
in content marketing
and what are they passionate about what
do you individually passionate about
in
digital marketing
what skills do you want to add to your
toolkit
and when do you want to do that
so we've got about 20 seconds
and about five seconds more
get your answers in and i will share
them with
all of you
so it's interesting seo
um about 50 of the audience about 60 of
the audience is interested in content
marketing skills
50
social media 50 analytics
about a quarter email
so
broad distribution but a lot in content
seo social
and
uh it's good to see that about 40 of the
audience is interested in getting
started right away so
we'll be sharing some things about how
to do that i want to share with you
again a thank you to bernadette i will
put into the chat here now
her linkedin
contact information
you can reach out to her
through linkedin
and let me put that into the chat so you
have that link
you can copy and paste
and
again thank you bernadette and thanks
everybody for being here i want to
let you know for people who have asked
how to get get started
one of the ways
is through our digital marketing
master's programs we have two of them
one of them is the digital marketing
associate which is for beginners that
gets you
your
proficiency in seo content marketing ppc
uh social media
all the different disciplines
and
if you are interested in going deeper
and adding more advanced
techniques in
different areas and adding more
different kinds of
electives for different skills there's
the digital marketing specialist masters
course i'm putting into the chat
links to both the program pages and how
to claim the 15 discount
that you have just for being here today
so
email ask us at simplylearn.net contact
one of our
learning consultants there
and
they can help you with questions they
can help you get enrolled and they can
help you claim that 15 discount
and
i have a question from someone who wants
to know more about the postgraduate
diploma that is a program that we offer
in conjunction with
purdue university it has a separate set
of benefits unfortunately we can't offer
the discount on that program today
but you can find that on our website
if that's of interest to you
and
i will invite everyone to come to our
next
webinar if you are interested in
learning about
digital technology leadership
if you have
friends who are interested i know that
some of you are entrepreneurs you've
asked the questions about
how to build up your own companies
so this session is a good one for you
and
it's with the director of it of
honeywell uh john dunn will be able to
answer a lot of questions and share a
lot of his experience in that area
so that again is in the chat
the link to register for that
and
with that we conclude our webinar we
invite you to all reach out to us
at our social media channels at
simplylearn on facebook and twitter
simply learned on linkedin
and we hope to see you at future
webinars and we hope to welcome you into
the simply learn learning community
so again thank you to bernadette
thank you
to all of you for being here
and
that concludes our webinar